[Music]
hey everybody welcome to grapefruit this
is a weird little side project then I
started a very long time ago I never
intended this to be an actual YouTube
series or ever to appear on YouTube it
was really just an experiment at the
time but it turned into the most smooth
coaster that I'd ever made and probably
even the smoothest coaster that I've
ever seen in planet coaster in general
so I really just wanted to make a series
out of this the reason that I started
making this coaster as a bit of an
experiment and why this turned into
anything at all was because I was told
of this weird little method at the time
in which you could make coasters in
plenty Kosar more smooth than in any
other way possible now Dustin came up
with this method and I'll explain a bit
more about it in a planet coaster
college video that I'll be putting up
very soon about how you can do it
yourself but it was basically a method
that quite some people knew about but
barely anybody had ever even tried
because it's something that takes a lot
of time the result that you're looking
at at the moment took many hours of
smoothing just smoothing alone to
actually get it to look this way so it's
actually kind of horrible to do but it's
something that kind of makes use or
makes misuse of the game's mechanics to
make coasters a lot more smooth than
your other ones can and it's absolutely
amazing so this was my little experiment
with that and the experiment was pretty
successful actually especially looking
at that 0-0 it's just something that you
cannot ever do if you build your coaster
another way so I figured I could just
turn this into a series and make it
quick which you're out of it now I'll be
doing a quick POV at the beginning here
just to show how this actually looks
when you're on it that's that it is a
little bit shaky though it's not that
it's not really the kind of unsmooth
that a planet coaster coaster usually is
where sometimes you've got some snappy
transitions or especially on rolls and
custom inversions you'll really start to
notice that the banking is uneven that's
not really the case here
but you can really see it kind of jag on
some curves and transitions here but
that aside it's really about as smooth
as I ever go on a coaster in planet
coaster the method itself basically
means that you have to build your entire
coaster out of four meter long pieces
and then afterwards smooth those pieces
out back and forth throughout the entire
track eight times and I know that sounds
very weird basically means you're going
to select four pieces at a time
hit smooth go to the next four pieces as
then move up one piece forward smooth
again move up one piece forward smooth
again then do the same thing backwards
through the entire track and repeat that
entire process four times and it's
pretty tiring but with pretty awesome
results as well so yeah that's basically
what this is I'll explain a bit more
about the method in the planet coaster
college video but I hope that this was a
pretty good intro as to how it looks and
why the result is so awesome
now without further ado let's get into
the time lapse and show you how the rest
of this is done now unfortunately I
don't really have much time lapse of me
doing the layouts at all since I really
just built the layout and Oscar which
realized that I had a go of mine
so I didn't record anything else which
was quite stupid only a little bit of
smoothing of the first drop over here
but you can kind of see me going back
and forth selecting four pieces at a
time and then humans move button the
entire time this is basically a process
that I had to go through for the entire
track though but the rest of this is
actually getting realistic touches in
all kinds of other ways a lot of my
videos so far have been a lot about
scenery and I think as a result it's
pretty easy to get the picture that
scenery is really my main stick when it
comes to planning coaster but I love
roller coasters as well and a quantum
enthusiast when it comes to following
all the latest news and watching every
single POV of every single roller
coaster on earth ever so I really wanted
to miss a bit more with that as well so
aside from just doing the
lay out as realistically as possible
here also try and experiment a lot with
making all kinds of other elements on
the coarser more realistic and one of
those was supports I wanted to get some
custom supports in here to make it look
much more be enemy and that also had to
come with some custom footers as well
for the supports to be in and that's a
lot of the stuff that I'm doing in here
one of the things that I really wanted
to get in which you can see over here
are those typical bnm little supports
which don't have one support going
straight down from the track and another
slanted support to support that but
instead the sort of triangular diagonal
sort of supports that make up this
interesting looking skyline of the
little and at the same time allow the
track to go underneath the little quite
a bit and it's really giving that very
typical bnm look that I was going for
with this coaster and also what I wanted
to add here is that typical being on
lift Hill motor and little chain return
so you've got the chain going up
underneath the track or on top of the
track actually underneath the cars and
actually hooking up the cars to go to
the top of the little but bnm courses
also have this separate chain lift
return which is the big beam that you
see going underneath the chain lift or
even underneath the entire LIXIL which
is where the chain goes back to the
beginning and allows you to pull up the
chain again only problem I kind of
realized was that I made my quick little
custom little motor there not to realize
that there is actually an in-game little
motor so I probably shouldn't have done
that that was a little bit of waste of
time I guess okay at least now
everything is custom and while the game
does come with a little motor it doesn't
have that sexy chain return and I really
needed that so we got that in anyway and
another very kind of difficult thing to
do actually is the track connectors or
strictly speaking the support connectors
because you've got the supports which
are the purple parts and the track which
is the yellow part so far so good but
you also need a piece which can connect
the both of them and beam em courses
have very typical looking connectors for
these places and I was trying my best to
sort of recreate them using the
eyepieces but they're a little bit too
bulky to get the exact look going but
from a distance I think they're very
hard to tell apart some still very happy
every time they turn out and here you
can see more of the entire process of
making a custom supports I just took the
point that I had earlier sort of placed
it in the place where I needed and this
is really just based on the supports
that the game already gave me so that
was quite easy and adjusted where
necessary the only thing here was that I
wanted the supports to go inward from
the curve and all sort of go toward the
middle and make the coaster a bit more
compact instead of going outward like
they did from the game itself so that's
something that I just quickly wanted to
change here but that aside the placement
of the supports is very much the same
still and it's really just in a few
places where I wanted the supports to
end a very typical bnm look that I
wanted to add my own custom supports
because it for the rest of the coaster
the supports are actually really good
and really glad with other supports look
in planning coaster in general they're
just some times where I feel making
custom supports makes it look a bit more
realistic same goes for this loop
support as well since very typical for
courses is to have these triangular loop
supports with different connectors and
that's something that I wanted to add to
the coaster as well to add a bit more
realism to it actually didn't add the
connectors yet so the yellow parts are
in there yet but they'll be there at
some point in time
also as another part of realism I wanted
to add a transfer track and a storage
strength for the coaster so at least
we'll be able to run two trains and if
there is any issue with maintenance or
anything related we can work one train
up to the storage shed or of course if
we're on a less busy day and we only
need to run one train and we're pretty
much still running fine with just that
train we can just store the other train
and save some money or not having to run
the other one so that's something that I
also wanted to quickly make over here of
course we don't quite have actual
functional transfer tracks which it's
all something that I would love to see
in one day wink-wink nudge-nudge but
it's still something that you can really
well make with all of the new metal
pieces especially given the fact that we
can recolor them now which is really
awesome and actually look really great
if you give them colors that are
slightly lighter than the colors of the
3d eyepieces since they do have a
slightly darker texture but it just
pretty much fits their color scheme as
well so I always quite happy with how
that turned out
and in this case I think I used some of
the pillar pieces to get a slightly
concrete looking footer and then we've
got some other eye pieces to make a
connector for that for the supports so
it all looks pretty good and I'm quite
happy with how that worked out
multiple not least I wanted to make a
quick little one I'm not sure what you
would call it actually but basically the
little electrical box where you actually
use the transit direct where one
employee is going to have to stand and
hit buttons and have the track switch so
you can move one train into the storage
that's basically what we're getting into
so basically all the mechanics of the
transfer track and also that I wanted to
move into some of the more aesthetic
points of the coaster which means
actually making a little shed and at
some later stage in this video actually
making a station for the coaster but
first off we've got the shed and to be
very honest as you might be able to tell
from what I'm doing here I'm really
focusing more on a realistic look and a
very sort of Six Flags Cedar Point
typical sort of amusement park but not
quite theme park look where everything
isn't so extremely detailed but it's all
very rough gritty industrial woods just
like the coaster and there's some basic
attention being drawn to landscaping and
this kind of scenery around that but
there's not really a theme to the
coaster it's not heavily themed at all
it's just put out there on a grassy
plain there's a simple park running by
and there are some basic stuff that you
need to have around your coaster put
that aside it's because that's really
the thing that it's all about so it's
it's very simple and it's got a sort of
style to it because I did want to choose
my colors and textures for these
buildings so I'm going with a very rough
gritty industrial look which means that
I'm getting some of the natural stones
out with some very sort of washed out
beige colors for a natural sandstone
sort of look getting some of the iron
roofs to get some corrugated walls in
there which works quite well with the
dark grey sort of iron beams that make
the sides and the highlights on this
building and even some yellow stripes
because it's it's sort of like
construction work it all feels like it's
in construction and sort of rough around
the edges and I really felt that that
sort of edginess was something that I
might as well add some yellow and black
stripes for as well because that just
all adds to the sense of danger and
the sense of it all just being a bit
mechanical and industrial maybe it's a
bit over the top but I still felt like
it was quite funny also something that
if you've ever played rollercoaster
country you might remember station
covers were actually a very big part of
scenery in there and there were hundreds
and I'm probably not even exaggerating
there hundreds of different types of
station covers that people designed and
a lot of them featured the yellow black
stripe sort of design which was quite
funny so definitely a shout out to the
roller coaster in three days with those
and also what I wanted to work on of
course was the cue slowed it on the
short side but I didn't want to go too
far with it and do kind of imagine this
coaster could be somewhere in a small
park and we do have a cattle pen over
here to haul in a few people but even
for the cue the rest of it is really
just going to be simple a simple metal
fence with some colours of the coaster
around it to sort of clear that it's
part of the coaster and kind of make it
a little bit more bright and nice even
though it's just metal and yeah that's
basically what's going on with the
Whitacre here it's very simple and very
straight to the point what I did try to
do though is to make it as clean as
possible so the challenge here was not
so much in trying to add as much detail
as possible or going for some sort of
more difficult atmosphere but really in
getting everything to connect nicely and
in a very clean way that nothing is
sticking out and everything just feels
very I don't know it feels very not so
message thing is if you're working with
a theme and you can just scatter barrels
around and have all kinds of different
senses have war sticking out in places
and have very these immunized buildings
and a sort of messy overall atmosphere
with many themes that can work but when
you're going for a very clean-cut simple
straight to the point industrial theme
it's something that I want to try to
avoid as much as possible and I want to
have a lot more harsh
and straight edges and things like that
it's basically when I'm trying to go for
in terms of the look here that's said I
did want to have a bit of contrast
because all of the materials are super
harsh so far we've got a lot of iron
elements and stone and all kinds of
colored hard elements to at least bring
some colored highlights into the
building but I figured as a final touch
having a wooden roof would actually work
quite well with that so we do have a
combination of some softer and hardened
materials going on here and especially
just the combination of an industrial
look with metal combined with some
rustic looking wooden elements is
something that I'm really big kind of so
that something that I wanted to try here
and instead of going with some standard
in-game roofs and standard colors I
think it would be nice idea to actually
make a custom roof out of pillars which
means that you have got more control
over what the colour of your roof is
going to be what the texture is going to
look like
since the texture is really just going
to be the way that you arrange all of
the different wooden pillars and which
would an object even make your roots out
of but it also gives you some
opportunities to have like more
variations because it's all sort of
gritty I wanted to make sure that all
the planks you've got a lot of different
planks have slightly different colors so
you can just go over the roof and hit
all sorts of run random pillars in it
and slightly change the wooden colour
texture of it so you've got those very
very minuscule differences in colors of
all the women things and to me at least
I think this makes a huge difference to
the look of the roof and if it were a
wall I would still do it since it really
just adds that slight sense of realism
and it seems not every blank has exact
this has exactly the same color
in real life wooden walls and roofs
especially anything like this where
you're going for that gritty look so
it's something that I quite like now for
the roof of the kettle pan here I tried
something else it's not quite a roof of
course it's more like pergola sort of
without a pergola for the rest of it's
actually kind of this I suppose it's
just held up by the big sort of hunky
clunky beams of iron and stone that kind
of offsets it again and a little bit of
detailing inside the station not too
much but enough so that it can look
realistic enough I suppose like it can
look believable and I also wanted to get
some some of those modern lighting felt
that quite worked quite well and for the
rest of it I was just spamming iron
fences and stuff to get those gritty
details in so onto the ramp of the queue
here and this is where I guess the point
of it trying to be as clean as to the
point as possible kind of comes back
here since instead of going with the
regular queue railings even on the
incline here I figured I would just take
the same fences and if take the fact
that there are going to be slanted and
diagonal and kind of weird-looking since
I just wanted to have the exact same
fences with the exact same colors as I
already do in the rest of the queue and
in the station as well just to make
everything fit together and then just
sort of decorate that a little bit in a
functional way with the metal beams
underneath it which also helps to sort
of make the station look a little bit
less square because obviously we've got
all these different buildings going on
which are pretty much use rectangles at
the station of the rectangle the
transfer track building is a rectangle
and then the roof over the capital
planning the queue is also a rectangle
and when it comes to building shapes
rectangles are kind of hard to work with
since you just can't really make much
that's interesting out of them like a
building that's made up of all kinds of
different smaller parts in different
directions and orientations is a lot
easier to make it look interesting then
if you've just got a rectangular
building
so having these lower parts I mean for
instance the kettle can move being
slightly lower than the station having
that slightly inclined sort of cue
quartz on the side of the station things
like that sort of help offset the square
look I feel and help make things a bit
more interesting than if it were just
the station building standing on its own
because in that case it would have just
been a very clear rectangular block and
that's something that I really try to
avoid as much as possible and a similar
thing kind of goes through the transfer
tag although it's going to be hidden a
little bit anyway so I didn't really add
too much to it besides it's really just
a simple transfer track building just a
simple storage shed only thing is that
it's also kind of used for maintenance
I suppose so I did of course add a door
into it and there is a lower level below
the course of track where employees
could actually be and check the courses
from underneath
check all the wheel curvatures and
everything and there will be like a
little bit of a decoration around as
well so it's not just the rectangles now
I went with the curved roof for a while
but I felt that looked too similar to
the station building so in the end I
went with a flat roof except it's not
entirely flat it's on a very slight
incline which is some interesting
information I think if I recall
correctly I don't know if I ever talked
about this but I think that buildings in
Switzerland are legally not allowed to
have flat roofs since that's just a
safety hazard you'll have rain and snow
stacking on your roof and you just need
it to have a slight incline which makes
it much better for weather conditions
and the same goes for a lot of flat
roofs very often when you think there is
a flat roof somewhere it's on a very
slight incline so at least the stuff
like rain can actually fall off of it so
this one as well is slightly inclined
but I think it also just makes it look a
little bit more interesting
and when it comes to the detailing and
everything I'm following largely the
same rules that I sort of established
for the station to make sure that
everything very neatly fits together
also I'm adding a little bit of extra
scenery around the side here to again
sort of get rid of the the blocky feel
of the station and have some more
interesting iron work to look at like
it's all kinds of layers and different
elements that overlap and go underneath
and in front of each other and it just
makes everything look a little bit more
interesting and in general a bit more
tangled up than just a simple
rectangular block so that's basically
what we've got going on over here it's
largely the same though so at this point
I was figuring it's very much just
following the rules that are already
sort of set for myself again this roof
is very slightly inclined especially
with the water coming off of the coming
off of the bigger roof of the station if
this were inclined the other way you
would totally get a waterfall over you
if you were standing at the front of the
queue and that's something that we
definitely don't want happening so it's
also a bit of a a water shelter I guess
if you're so brave to ride the coaster
in the rain that said this is going to
be a little bit of a spoiler but with
the climates that this coaster is going
to be in I don't think there's actually
going to be too much rain it's going to
be pretty Mediterranean anyway lost but
not least I wanted to work a little bit
on some sceneries around the Q although
it's not quite going to be too much just
a simple lamp and that's one that we'll
be able to copy around there of course
I'll color it as well and make it
something other than white and here's
more of that process of taking the
different wooden beams that we have in
the roofs and giving them slightly
different colors to make everything look
a bit more interesting and natural and
if I remember correctly lost but not
least I went into the exit side of the
station is that something that I haven't
show off so far and just added a very
simple roof and support structure to
that as well
to finish off the station building and
that is basically also it for this
episode so I want to thank you guys so
much for watching the first episode of
grapefruit I know this is a little bit
of a weird series but I'll try to keep
it up for two episodes that is the plan
and then get a quick POV and everything
out about this koi story and yeah
that'll be my very quick just little fun
stint so thanks for watching I will see
you guys the next episode
[Music]